Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
August fucking 27th,
August 27th.
What's going on?
How are you?
Um,
as you know,
I don't have a lot of guests on a,
on my podcast.
Every once in a while I'll have someone that interests me,
a middle leather chair.
I'm not like constantly fighting here.
I'm just adjusting my weight.
I have one of my oldest friends in this business.
I've known this man since 1995 when we were a couple of,
nobody's going around fucking New York trying to get spots.
He has his name.
Oh,
I just introduce you.
Unbelievable comedian.
Mr Tom Pop.
Everybody nice to be here.
Bill 95.
That's amazing.
So I was only doing stand up for two years when we miss that.
Right.
You were already really good.
93.
I wasn't good.
I was loud.
I was loud and fast.
Well,
I remember,
uh,
Geraldo rest,
his soul used to tell me that the way you used to stand on stage,
you were in some sort of like warrior one or warrior too.
I was sort of weird.
Lean.
I wa I called it the lens was that lunch.
I would like lean.
Yeah.
I would kind of like bend my one leg and kind of lunch that way and talk to that
part of the audience.
Then I would lunge the other way,
talk to them about it.
Got Laughs.
So yeah,
I thought they'd probably be like,
he's a character.
He's thinking of character.
We can build a sitcom around this guy.
Look at,
he's a young guy.
Like back then that was the whole thing.
Long bushy curly hair.
Ah,
um,
uh,
probably about 25 pounds heavier than I am now.
Oh,
you were heavier?
Yeah.
And uh,
are you a party in back then?
Who was like my crazy,
uh,
my wife calls it when she saw a tape of it.
She didn't know me back then.
She saw me probably 10 years after that.
And when she saw,
I don't know if you have like a good tape of you when you first started,
but there's like,
they're all so classic and uh,
she sighed and said,
it looked like my crazy brother showed up in,
came to town and started doing comedy.
You're Roger Clinton showed up.
Right?
And say I did kind of look Roger Clinton this had,
they kind of a,
almost a mullet,
but not really.
I got one in a,
I forget where the hell I was.
I was doing some local Boston show.
Yeah.
I mean it was taped.
Someone's gotta have the tape somewhere and I was wearing basically the clothes
that I wore to the dental office that day.
I was still working them.
I was definitely wearing the pants here.
Right.
So I had like powder from the rubber gloves and God knows how much germs on me
cause I like the only way to make the Gig was I had to work and then just jump
in my car and go.
So I brought a chair,
a chair,
I brought his shirt.
So I had,
uh,
I had on navy blue Docker's Oh.
And then I had a shirt.
Uh,
it was navy blue stripe and like,
like pea soup,
green horizontal stripes.
I had a big red afro tucked in and a shirt tucked in now no grunge had already
hit at that point.
Nice.
So I in [inaudible] 92 so it was already like Roger's already going.
So it was like if he tucked in your shirt,
you were part of the 80s.
So the show I believe was on tucked,
might not have been now that I think about it,
but I was,
I just remember I was pointing at the crowd when I every like,
like Annunciation,
I was doing this thing.
You remember when Trump did that thing,
you're fired that little snake thing here with his hand and they made fun of it
so much he stopped doing it.
Right.
Um,
which is kind of funny to think about now.
That's interesting though.
You with the pointing as you're telling the jokes.
I mean with the lunging.
Yes.
Uh,
because the two guys that I want it to be kind of bad ass,
like I didn't want to be like them,
but I can look back and think like Bill Hicks and Denis leary.
We'd get in the audience's face and they would kind of like jab at them kind of
that way.
Oh,
okay.
Are you watching those guys at that time?
I didn't even know who bill Hicks was until after he died.
Oh really?
Well,
I mean because Bill Hicks was not getting on mainstream stuff.
He had done a couple of letterman's,
but back then,
you know,
if he didn't know to look for them,
if you missed his letter in spot,
you just missed it.
I found them by mistake on Caroline's comedy hour.
Oh,
okay.
To Caroline's comedy hour when Caroline's was down in another location I think
by the seaport or something before our time.
And I saw him and he would get like right in their face.
He would at the edge of the stage,
he bend all the way down with a cigarette.
Right.
Someone's face and yell about Britney Spears or whatever.
No,
he was gone before Britney spears.
I just felt at that time like you have no materials so you just,
you know you're funny but you have no real skill.
You got some stuff,
but then it's just pure energy.
It's just what I think that that's because I was totally like introverted,
but saw that that was me just sort of,
I think it was just,
that was me.
I was miming throwing shit against the wall.
I think every job that I was doing,
but then as we came up through the ranks,
what amazed me about you was the way that you could like always worked.
Totally clean and like you,
I mean,
you know,
we came up,
you know SD would be given us the light spots.
That's how it is.
You've got to earn,
you got to earn the earlier ones.
Yeah,
and I am.
You'd go on after Godfrey crushing,
you know all of these guys.
You go on at the my filth and you'd go out there and just totally sport coat on,
squeaky clean.
Well and just boom,
you just killed.
I did go through some phases when,
especially when it got to the seller where I was,
you know,
going up after it's hell where for a good month I thought I've got to be
dirtier.
I've got to,
yeah,
I've got to do something.
So I started coming up with filthier stuff and I'm telling you,
just the audience knew.
They don't know me at all.
That is not this guy.
They knew I was not the guy saying these were like,
it wasn't,
it did not fit.
And you know what's funny is what you're saying right now is all you had to say
after Dave.
Yeah.
Like I'd like to continue right in that dark world,
but look at me folks.
I'm not that guy.
Yeah,
you didn't have the courage or like the,
the,
the wherewithal to do that.
So my only cure for it was don't watch anybody before I go on,
just to completely stay alone and wait for them to come and get me like last
minute.
Like,
Hey,
they're calling your name and then go down.
Isn't that amazing note.
But I think people that are successful will find ways,
you know,
in situations like that they actually come up,
they'll come up with their own sort of exercise.
Yeah.
To be all right.
Well if I just don't see it then I don't have to like deal with it.
Yeah.
And um,
some way to preserve whatever you got to kind of do.
I did something last week when I was on Conan.
Right?
Uh Huh.
I did something that I learned at the comedy cellar.
It was a comedy cellar is small as it is.
Yeah.
It always seems so gigantic to me because it was like this place you wanted to
get into st would be watching your sets.
The fucking wait staff would report back to management and shed energy and you
just never felt like,
you know,
it takes a good eight years before you feel like you're in it.
Totally.
So I remember Patrice had done something on stage.
I don't know what happened.
He had done something,
so they called a meeting.
It was,
this is fucking hilarious.
They call this meeting to at the comedy cellar.
Okay.
And the three people showed up on all the comics.
It was me and Bobby.
I was living with Bobby Kelly.
Bobby's like,
dude,
we gotta go to the meeting.
She's going to take away I spots.
And I'm like,
I know.
And we both went down there fricking frack to Boston guys.
We'd go down there.
It was us two and David Tell,
oh my God,
Patrice,
who the whole fucking meeting was about,
didn't even show up of course.
And everybody else was kind of in and they say,
I got get a fucking going down there.
But anyway,
we went in there and I remember waiting for a SDN Manny to get their rest,
his soul.
And I just was,
I was absent.
It was the middle of the day and I could not believe how small the club was.
Right.
And I was just like,
oh my God.
I mean I could literally,
yeah,
move all the chairs out of here in 11 minutes by myself.
It is.
Yeah.
Sometimes I'll go down to,
to go to use the restroom even now,
and you go down there and it's just empty and everything's pushed aside.
So they can mop and it really is like a closet and it's because when,
I don't know what it is about that room,
when it gets full,
it's and yes.
And it just,
it,
it becomes this other,
this energy thing that you just saw.
And then when it's,
everybody's gone.
Yeah.
And they're like going like,
this is this place.
It's like,
you know,
so anyways,
so I went,
I had to go to Conan and I just so happened I was ready for once before the,
you know,
right as the guy got there to pick you up.
Uh,
so I got there like 15 minutes early.
There was nobody there,
so I was like,
you know,
I always just walk out there.
Why don't I just walk out and take a look at it?
Yeah.
Just so I can really have in my head how big it is.
Oh.
You know,
it was still pretty big and that's,
yeah,
that's that smell.
But I mean,
but it wasn't like it's your space.
I wanted to be more grounded.
Right.
So I went up,
I looked at the drum kit and stuff,
sat down and played for like two seconds and then like walked around and talked
to a couple of people.
A few people said hello.
Yeah.
And then it just kind of felt like,
and I was just looking at smart.
Yeah.
That's so smart.
So cause even when you leave,
you've done the show a bunch,
but when you could walk back out it feels new again.
It's not your home.
Yes.
So I did the new again thing before the cameras were on.
Nice.
And then so then when I went out there I felt like I was,
you know,
the most present.
I didn't have that same outer body experience where afterwards I had all would
always look at Andy and be like,
was that good?
Like,
like basically what happened.
I totally,
because the whole time you're doing it,
you're thinking like nowadays too,
it's like,
then I just end my fucking career right there.
What did I say?
You know,
is this group going to come at me?
Or fat people going to say this?
Like,
ah,
you know all of that shit.
So anyway,
speaking of careers,
yes you are on this podcast.
Not because you like me.
Wow.
Not because she wanted to come over here and smoke a cigar afterwards with some
finding out you don't have time.
Oh,
I with Tom Papa.
Um,
not only an incredible comedian.
You also bake your own bread.
Yes,
I do.
What you've been doing for years on end you,
you were actually nice enough to offer to teach me and I've just never found
time to get over there.
And I brought you bread.
Oh you pick a year ago.
You remember I brought it to like two times.
I vaguely remember cause it's gone that quick and it brings it over in a little
basket with this old lady.
Little towel over the top of it and you're like,
ah,
like you don't even need butter.
You made us a,
uh,
what did you make us?
I always get a sour sour dough.
Yeah.
Ah,
good stuff.
I got good on me.
And Nia basically ate the whole loaf talking about what we were going to eat it
with that night.
And we,
we're just not the whole thing.
We were like,
we got to finish this.
So now all of a sudden,
yeah.
Um,
your,
your professional and your hobby life have now blurred here and you have a new
cooking show coming out today,
I guess,
right?
Monday a week.
A week from Labor Day.
Oh,
Labor Day.
So a week from today,
what's the exact date?
Uh,
September,
third,
Thursday,
10 o'clock at night.
10 o'clock east called baked.
It's called baked.
And No,
you're not putting any wheat in the bread,
man.
Hey Man.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
it's not really a cooking show as much as a food show.
Like I'm not going to,
well I guess I,
I guess I am cooking basically what I did.
Well,
it's not going to be eight episodes of watching you cook bread now.
Okay.
Exactly.
That's,
uh,
that's kind of what I thought it was going to be.
And they're like,
this is going to be over in an episode.
Do you have a hundred different kinds of loaves of bread?
Right?
You can make,
so we can get there to syndication.
So what I was doing,
I started baking it.
I started getting really good at it and when I would travel around on the road
doing stand up during the day,
I would visit bakeries.
I would go check them out and I was just trying to learn like see what flower
they were using,
talk to them,
that kind of thing.
Yeah,
you got into it.
I got into it and they caught wind of it and thought it would be a cool show
because I'm already doing it.
I'm going to these places and then you know I'm going to learn.
I'm super curious about it and they didn't have any show that just dealt with
baked goods.
Can you back up for a second?
How did they catch wind of it?
I got that Alexis in your fucking house or something.
How do they catch wind and I are a comic killing a day and you're going to
bakeries because I started talking about it on social media as asked about an on
Rogan's podcast.
I talked about it on Conan and in the New York Times did an article on people
with sourdough starters.
You know,
the sourdough starter is the literal mother,
the mother.
I hate that.
I hate this.
I saw the thing,
there's,
there's like a thing in France that some of them have,
they're like a,
they're like a couple hundred years old.
Yeah.
Like you just keep feeding it some sort of bacteria or,
no,
you just keep feeding it flour and water and it eats,
it stays alive yet it's the act of yeast in there.
And so you've got to feed it flour and water and it eats it.
And so it's like they've had a goldfish that they'd been feeding for like the
last since like the early 18 hundreds.
Yeah.
And it's a little vague,
like when people say it's a hundred years old,
I mean,
cause you like nobody ever spelled it.
It has its origin.
Like it has it,
you will have,
it will connect to however long you've been feeding it,
but you're dumping a lot of it and then new flower and water's going in.
But it's just a cool story.
Yeah.
You know,
and uh,
now I feel like a novice,
like people do care about it.
People do like hang on to them,
pass them down to other people in their family.
And it is a thing like you might have two of them and they're in my refrigerator
and I've been on the road now for a week.
I just got home today and I know when I leave you I'm going to go home and feed
them cause it's been a week.
If you don't feed it,
it slowly starts to become less active.
It has no food to eat and then it starts creating its own alcohol and that's it.
When you come back,
there'll be like a layer of alcohol on top of it now sold your Looch,
you're like a microbrewery.
Yeah,
exactly.
Oh it's literally calls who literally how pure alcohol booze that called hooch.
Yeah,
it's a fermentation.
This is already the most informative podcasts I've ever done.
That's fucking awesome.
So the New York Times did an article on people with their sourdough starters and
just,
you know,
I've been doing it for like a year and they came into my house and took pictures
of me with my starter and I was in the food section.
This is,
I'm not doing anything,
show busy with this.
I'm just baking bread with my daughter have,
isn't that always how it comes about when you're,
when you're not trying not at all.
And uh,
my friends back east slope in the New York Times and the calling me that day,
like,
what are you doing?
What's,
why are you in the food section?
So it just became a thing
and then people started sending me things on Twitter and Facebook or whatever,
uh,
showing me that there are attempts at baking like,
and that's a massive subculture yeah.
Of,
it's not even just people who bake,
like specifically bake bread.
Yeah.
People who are into bourbons.
Like there's all these subcultures thing that when you all of a sudden get into
it.
Totally.
Yeah.
You just feel like open the door a little bit.
All of a sudden you see those like,
you know,
a million people in.
They're like,
yeah,
yeah.
You're like,
wow,
look at all these Instagram accounts of people doing what I'm doing.
So is it just kind of,
uh,
took off and was super fun.
And I also,
at the same time that I started baking it,
I also started getting on this kick of,
uh,
this is,
why are we the first generation it bread has been around for thousands of years.
Why are we the generation that's being told we shouldn't eat bread?
Why all of a sudden are we now like,
no,
you're the new human beings that Cammy bread.
And I was like,
there's something wrong here.
And then we started baking this bread.
It's just flour,
water,
salt and yeast.
That's all that's in it.
And with the bread,
I would buy,
my daughter's in the supermarket trying to get them good bread,
had 30 ingredients in it,
right?
Chemicals,
sugars,
glucose,
all this other
isis,
it was all in there.
Yeah.
Russian poisoned [inaudible].
And
I started giving that bread to my friends that have problems with eating bread.
And they had no problems.
We were eating a lot of bread and we weren't getting fat.
And I was like,
this is the pure thing.
This is what bread really is.
So then I started going off on this kick in my acts and it started,
you know,
a permeating other parts of the Bible.
It was in my book where I was just like,
we should be allowed to celebrate in life.
You should be allowed.
Can I pitch in episode?
Yes.
An episode cause you got eight already in the can.
Okay.
You're next season.
[inaudible] Tom teaches bill how to bake bread or even just great.
Even just for the website.
That would be awesome.
I would love,
I am on this new diet that I've been doing for like the last three weeks and
I've been,
you know,
keeping the muscle and dropping all the fat and I love how I look and
everything,
but it's just like I,
I,
you know,
and I come,
I got to have a piece of bread every once in awhile.
Every once in awhile.
And you eat,
you what?
Okay,
I'll do this shit that I used the [inaudible] part of my generation.
You might always wonder bread,
my son stay comes on Wonderbread and the grease would be going through the bread
.
You have to eat it quick before we went through.
Oh yeah,
you're going to like a fork or something.
I um,
and I stand by dude.
I,
I had that today.
I would have to take a nap immediately,
but it would be effing delicious and a child's sense.
Memory Foam,
but your stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
Ihs,
your brand.
I was like,
I got to call my parents.
I mean it was just,
it was just like,
it was like a wholesome,
yeah.
Holidays,
everything that like,
you know,
when,
when all the bs slows down in life,
right.
You know,
you just got passed something or maybe it's the holidays,
you've got a few days off,
you just have time,
but you actually have free time to hang with the people in your life.
Like,
oh,
this is what it's and so could be.
Right,
exactly.
This is what it could be.
And it's not every day.
I mean these are special moments in your life,
you know?
I mean,
basically the way the show goes is I just pictured you talk in your family,
like don't get Yoast today.
It's special thing.
There's bread in the house all the time now.
Like when I go on the road,
if I'm gone for a while,
they get for the first time they call me.
They're like,
when are you coming back?
And it's not because he want to see if you realize your kids,
they're going to talk about you like some like grandmother from the early 1900
stones.
There was always the smell of bread in our house.
That's right.
I'm out.
I'll always remember her.
I remember her when she passed the casket smelled like east east to discuss the,
sorry,
I should've said bread.
It just took a whole nother angle on there.
So what's your favorite?
Uh,
so,
so basically I go around to all these different cities.
I come into a city and I visit five of the best baked goods I can find a bakery.
I'm a sandwich place with amazing roles,
a pizza place,
whatever it is.
What we're dealing with doe and that kind of thing and you quickly realize this
back to it being special,
you quickly realize there doesn't,
there is no need for a bakery in a town.
You know what I mean?
Like there's,
you need the cops,
you need the fire department,
you need the power,
you need the the water,
you need all this stuff.
A bakery is a special little place that's just happens to be at the town that
when you want to treat yourself or get something nice for your family,
that's when you go to the bakery.
It's this nice little celebration in your everyday life.
You don't go there every day,
you know most of the time.
So all these people are creating this really special stuff and you go in there
and you feel good and that you should be celebrating your life like this is it
like this.
We're not going to this.
This is prime time.
This is when we're really going to enjoy ourselves.
You take your daughter and walk into a bakery and give her a cookie.
That is a special moment.
That's a special thing.
You know when she,
when she turned a year and a half last month,
I actually,
I went to a bakery and I bought her a cupcake and put one and a half candles in
it and sang happy one and a half.
Yeah.
Years old.
God,
she just looking at me like,
when can I eat the seat?
Nice song that I don't know what's going on here and get [inaudible] Lincoln.
I have the,
yeah,
this is special for you,
but I really feel like,
uh,
it's,
it's just,
it's a celebration.
Life should be a celebration.
You don't eat this stuff all the time.
You don't want to,
you know,
you,
you want to be in shape.
You don't want to get diabetes,
but you should enjoy it.
We'll do an episode.
I'll teach you how to make a pie crust.
You teach me how to make bake some bread and there would be great.
We should do it now.
I gotta be honest with you.
Like I,
I just,
uh,
the whole idea of having a comedian who bakes,
you know,
it's weird right now I'm just saying,
I'm like,
what a home run for a show.
Oh right.
And then you're going to go check out all these cool bakeries.
Like I dunno,
like,
Hey,
I've had diners drive it and the tides,
it just seems like everybody's always eating like the Burgers,
the Tacos,
the Burrito's,
the pizza.
Yeah.
They've had all of those shows,
but I haven't seen a guy big through the bakeries now and like,
you know,
for years.
Yeah.
I've been,
you know,
sort of like a gay bashed in a way that I actually know how to bake and make
pies and stuff.
And I'm like,
why?
It's awesome.
And Women Love Ya.
I remember,
do you know how to bake?
Like they love?
Oh completely.
There's a whole,
there was a whole article about a women that get turned on by these guys that
bake bread.
Remember you.
Absolutely.
It's like,
it's,
it's like having a saint for me cause I'm such an asshole.
It takes down a lot of my shit that I do.
You know what I mean?
Fuck.
You know that's the edge off.
Yeah.
Like make a scene.
It's a supermodel.
He yells,
he's cutting people off,
but he makes a hell of a pot.
Even your voice changed and thanks a hell of a fun.
Take some of the edge off you.
Uh,
you brought up pie.
Was it last Christmas?
Was it around the holidays?
I can't remember.
Brought me a pie and the center wasn't cooked.
And you always show you were so bummed out.
I'm gonna tell you why.
Because we will renting a house.
Can I email my shit hole one fixed up?
Yup.
And what happened was the door was slightly ajar.
Let the heat out.
No,
I bet you I'm still remember,
send me a picture of it.
I made sure.
Yeah.
Cause I felt so bad.
I made you a,
uh,
pumpkin bread for Halloween and it's the easiest fucking thing.
Yeah.
It's just a concoction.
You pour it in the thing,
you throw in the oven and you're done and you leave it.
Yeah.
And it wasn't done.
So I had to tell you to put it back in.
And you were able to fix it though.
But I was,
I was so embarrassed.
And then the fact that you're like this,
you know me is such a good baker,
you're in,
you're in the food section of the Times.
I get a couple of hits on Facebook when I make a pie,
but,
but you know what,
that I remember distinctly like we just ate around the raw part and it was
delicious.
And like that's the cool thing.
Like you don't realize you messed this stuff up.
I'll still screw up reds because it takes,
it's a three day process and if you mess up along the way,
you're gonna get a flat frisbee.
But I'm telling you the flat Frisbee is delay still is.
Yeah.
Just cause it doesn't look good.
Just put some butter on it.
You just,
Oh yeah.
God.
What have you been up to as far as,
uh,
you've been traveling the road,
promoting the show,
you've been doing some dates.
What he'd been up to head a uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's not really slowed down.
I have.
Um,
I had five jobs from April until just recently where I was doing my standup,
of course.
And then I had a book come out,
so I had to tour around with the book.
I took over the writing for live from here,
which was prairie home companion.
The garrison retired and,
um,
Chris Lee took over as the host and,
uh,
I took over the comedy of it and the writing of it.
And,
uh,
I also do a monologue each week on it.
And then,
um,
and then I had my podcast when I come to Papa podcast and radio show for Sirius
and uh,
and then baked.
And then when they,
when the red show came,
you know,
as happens in production,
they,
they are like,
yeah,
we might make it,
we might make it.
And they're like,
we want eight in a month.
So on top of touring with the radio show and with my standup and the book tour,
the bread show got thrown on top of it.
So on the bread show,
you're probably thinking of saying,
I can't get to go.
It's a fun little thing that'll do.
It's fine.
We'll do the pilot wrote me a couple of bucks.
This is cool.
We'll do a pilot.
Who knows?
You know,
I wasn't,
I the,
the beautiful part of this is I have no show Biz anxiety about this.
I still don't,
I still don't.
I everything else,
you know,
you make stuff,
you sell it,
you try and get it on the air.
You push.
Yeah.
But I also think if you towards a comic and you have your own podcast,
you're making enough money that I don't have any showbiz stress where I love
doing my TV show.
Absolutely love doing it.
But like,
I'm not like in the unemployment line,
you're right.
If it doesn't go.
Yeah.
If it doesn't go,
what's your help?
It goes by the way anybody's listening.
Yeah.
And just treat drone out there.
Here's not appreciating her,
Cheryl.
Um,
yeah,
but this show I completely,
I'm like,
look,
we can do a show about it.
That'd be great.
I'd love to share it with more people.
That's awesome.
If you don't make a show about it,
I'm still gonna go to the bakery in Cleveland when I get there.
You know what I mean?
So how much time did she say did you buy?
Did you have to carve out,
spends a schedule to keep doing it?
I just threw it on top of everything else.
So while I was doing the book tour,
while I was doing the standup,
but I was doing all this other stuff.
I was doing episodes of this show,
uh,
that are going to start airing.
And I literally have not been in my home for a full week since April.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It was just,
it just all,
it was like a tsunami.
Everything,
a perfect storm.
It all just hit at the same time.
How do you handle that?
I just go,
I just go and having a family is,
uh,
end up,
you know,
I want to be with them.
I literally built,
my kids are 16 and 13 now and I was like,
I literally,
before all of this stuff hit the fan.
I literally said to myself,
I'm going to be smarter about how I tour.
These are the only a couple more years here before everybody starts taking off
on their own.
I'm going to be around a little bit more.
Yeah.
And boom.
As soon as I said it,
I was gone.
Oh,
okay.
And so that's,
that's the industry.
I know you young people in the industry just say out loud.
You know what?
I'm going to move back east.
Just say that now.
The show Biz Unifor universe will let you move back east and it'll get you
something after you've given up your apartment and all that.
Do that.
Just tap into,
was that just happened?
A Dean Del Rey?
Oh yeah.
Dean del Ray's.
I'm getting all these cs by coastal announced,
so anybody,
so he went to New York,
like I'm going to be out there for a while doing spots a minute,
the seller,
Blah Blah dude,
he gets,
I'll tell you,
was there for like two weeks he got Conan?
No,
he just got caught.
He's going to come back.
It's hilarious.
He's actually,
he's on Conan tonight with Mark Marin.
Oh,
nice.
I'm going to try to go over there for the,
uh,
for the taping.
Yeah.
That'll be fun.
These,
he's such a good guy.
He's got,
and Dean,
uh,
you know,
I haven't watched him that much,
but over the last,
you know,
several years he just got you just,
some guys just turn the corner.
They just know exactly what they're starting to do.
Like he got so tuned into his voice.
Yeah.
He's just,
he's Dean onstage and offstage.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a killer now.
Now he opens from me.
He gets,
he gets like sustained rounds of applause when he's done through an,
I had to go on after him and Todd rex,
you have to go on at the Todd rex fucking monster.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And both taught as this thing.
What did people love him?
Yeah.
Like he's one of these,
these like a big kid.
Love them adult's level.
Right.
And he is like,
he's like a legit headliner.
Wow.
And put both of those guys on before you,
yeah,
I did want it.
But what's good is all,
but then people come out like a,
and they get to see like a full show rather than some like,
you know,
some cupcake you put on in front of you that's up there.
Hey.
Uh,
I know there's been crazy here.
You will notice with raindrops,
some are bigger than others.
I did a show last night
in,
uh,
in or the other night in,
um,
a Michigan,
northern Michigan and it was as a performing arts center,
this Nice Theater,
beautiful place up in like,
I've never been that bakery,
nice bakery.
Uh,
no opener.
No,
I just walked out and just did it.
It was kind of lonely,
like hanging out during the day and stuff.
But um,
I have to say it was kind of,
you have to do more time.
You know,
you're doing more like an hour and a half,
but,
uh,
I
really liked it.
Yeah,
we'll do that.
Yeah.
Well I do like 90 minutes anyway on top of those guys.
But if I have one guy who does like 15,
if I have two guys who both to 10.
Oh,
okay.
And I'm trying like,
but you ever just walk out,
you ever just go with nobody?
Yes.
Have I done nobody on the road?
I,
I'm only a times.
Yeah.
Am I,
it becomes a different thing.
It is a different thing.
I think it would be weird at a club.
Uh,
yes.
Just because of what the club,
there's so much commotion going on.
Yeah.
And there's so many drinks.
She got to get out.
So much food to get out and all the fuck all that pomp and circumstance has to
happen.
There's a lot going on.
And then when the headliner comes on it's like,
now we have your undivided attention until we drop all the checks.
Yeah.
So there's always commotion going on with the clubs,
but they're like in a theater I think,
um,
if he comes in evening with rather than yeah.
Show like I saw,
uh,
who did I see?
I saw Billy Connolly.
Uh Huh.
I saw him in New York about 10 years ago and if I remember,
yeah,
cause he did like two hours.
Yeah,
he did two fucking hours.
It was unbelievable.
And like that.
At that point,
that's when guys were kind of like,
if you did like an hour,
it was like,
wow,
do you ever want headlining was 45 minutes.
Everybody did 45 45 yeah.
Insane fucking joke.
Same.
I feel like now if I don't do like an hour and 20 I'm ripping them off,
you know?
And I know.
Yeah.
It's weird thing.
You know what's weird about it too is that it's kind of like when you do pushups
,
like if you say you're going to do 20 pushups,
18 1920 are really hard.
If you tell yourself you're doing 25 all of a sudden 2124 25 or art like
external about that 80 to 90 to heart 25 is going to see like a fucking zillion
miles away.
But I know we just mean you're shooting yet.
It just your head,
your head does something.
You say,
I'm going to go do an hour and a half tonight.
Yeah.
That's just the way it is.
If you say you're doing an hour,
all of a sudden you're panting to get to an hour.
Alright.
Hey,
you want to answer some questions here?
If you want to help me out,
I give people advice on this,
this podcast.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
if any of this is gonna ruin your bread shelf,
they just let me know.
I'll give you the last week I uh,
somebody mentioned that,
you know,
I actually,
my dumb ass I went on like,
I was like,
let's see what's going on in the world and know and um,
I don't even know if I want to drag you into this,
but like Trump said that said they're killing white farmers in a,
in South Africa,
which has been happening.
If one,
I never condoned it.
I didn't say it wasn't a big deal.
I would just,
I was talking about what he pays attention to,
which,
you know,
I don't think if they were Puerto Rican farmers he would give a fuck.
And I am,
call me a reverse racist.
But I am basing that on the fact that when there was regular people and then neo
Nazis involved,
he was sitting there going like,
well,
you know,
you can kind of see both sides of the story.
Yeah.
So anyways,
uh,
so this guy wrote,
he wrote in from Cape Town,
so we've got a bunch of people from Europe.
All right.
Saying,
oh,
but blub,
blub,
blub.
They're just like,
mate.
Then they're not there.
Right.
So we didn't listen to them.
All right,
so this guy is from Cape Town right there.
Uh,
how's it going,
Billy?
Uh,
I'm from,
I'm from Cape Town Africa.
I'm a big
fan.
I listen to podcasts every week.
Yada,
Yada.
Care for a visit.
Yeah,
I'd love to.
I'd love to go there.
I'd go there.
I have two topics I want to put out there.
First by country.
Got some air time in the news last week due to a tweet by the Donald Guy.
Now,
just to recap,
I don't know what this guy's tone is,
but I've read some of the other ones that are all like,
why didn't you fucking read about it with Ilp?
Your mouth.
All right.
Now just to recap,
he basically mentioned investigating far murders in land expropriation without
payment in South Africa based on race.
Why are we getting involved in this?
Yeah,
I know.
Why are we getting involved anyways?
Yeah,
I bet one of the farmers was going to sell him land to build a golf course.
We have to stop it.
All right.
News outlets like BBC,
CNN,
etc.
Were quick to point out that these claims were baseless.
And then if you look at the crime statute,
actually see a decline in the farm based attacks.
Though I don't live,
I don't watch.
He got into it because a Tucker Carlson did a thing on it.
Oh I,
you know what I should cause I don't watch the news.
Yeah.
Cause all it does is give me eggs.
It's just,
it's a half hour.
Bangs it with no solution.
Then all this shit that I wasn't worried about,
I now have to add to this shit I already was worried about.
So why would I do that to myself?
And you're powerless to do anything.
All right.
Just to set the record straight,
I can tell you that if you search deeper and speak to the average South African,
they would tell you a different story.
Being a farmer or a farmer worker is by far the most dangerous job you can have
around here due to the number of attacks and the cold bludder blooded barbaric
nature of these attacks.
Uh,
there is no doubt that the number of attacks has grown in number and in
brutality in recent years.
Yet these attacks are not widely reported in the accuracy.
The statistics on the farmers have been appointed dispute ever since the end of
apartheid.
Anyone you talk to?
Uh,
yeah.
The whole fucking thing is there was brutal attacks to get the land and then a
brutal form of government and now there's a brutal reaction to it is my limited
understanding to it.
And I'm not saying any of that was right.
I was just saying it's interesting what,
oh,
the orange headed lunatic decides to pay attention to.
Right,
exactly.
He's all I'm saying,
I mean this is,
and I've even said the last election was 2:00 AM at a bar.
You had to go home with somebody you didn't want to leave with either one,
but you had to leave with somebody.
So I am not,
I am not picking a side politically arrange shit.
Anyways.
Anyone you've talked to can tell,
tell you have multiple,
multiple of their close friends or relatives who have been attacked,
uh,
had been affected by an attack regardless of rate race.
Yet this is not helped by the fact that many political rallies or met with
chance of kill the Bora,
the farmer kill the farmer.
These political parties are basically garnering support on the false promise of
land and wealth to everyone.
Yay.
Communism.
What do you mean gay communism that happened in our country?
Yeah.
We got to rebel against these English guys and then all the rich Fox,
once we kicked him out and moved into the rich guys houses,
right.
And continues to taxes.
This is,
I love when they blamed forms of government.
Yeah.
Is there a form of government that works?
I don't think there is because every cause you get
at the end,
you have human beings with unchecked power on some level at the top and it just,
that's right.
So we are,
some people taste the good life and they don't want to give it back.
No,
no.
That's what's going on in Nicaragua right now.
What's going on about someone else's problems?
It's basically the students are rioting and trying to take the government back
and the guy who they're trying to take the government back took the government
for the people when he was a student,
but then he got fat and happy and now he's like the dictator who doesn't want to
let it go.
Yeah.
Whenever.
Whenever you taste the good life,
nobody wants to let it go.
Now you get the extra food,
you get the best booze,
the best women.
Oh my God.
All of that.
And it's just big nice silk robe.
Yeah.
People are cooking your meals.
He's sitting in the hot tub.
Yeah.
You going to get out of that thing to go help somebody less fortunate than you?
No,
that's not how people are wired.
No.
They put up gates around their home and they say,
I'm going to keep this.
This is,
I'll read,
I'll read more about this stuff.
I,
I'll,
I'll definitely look up and I know,
but why,
but back to your thing about the orange guy pointing this out and bringing us
into like,
I understand that's a big problem when you read about it,
it's like,
Ooh boy,
this is a mess.
Don't we have her own messes?
Like the aren't,
aren't,
aren't like why do I have to jump into this one?
I mean there's stuff like that.
No human being to human being yet you're supposed to care.
You do care,
but I can't,
how much time you know you could care about everything we get into the Nicaragua
thing is a huge thing.
I mean it's,
I don't even know what's going on there.
All I know is this country is fucking bankrupt and because we're fighting a war
that has no set ending and you're not allowed to ask about it.
And I don't want to bring this shit up.
Boy,
you got a fucking show coming out.
Um,
it's just one of those things where it's just like,
I don't understand why if I ask like,
hey,
how are we going to pay for this?
Hey,
when are we coming back?
All of a sudden I don't support the troops.
I'm not American.
And I just became like,
I just got my,
I'm,
I'm part of Isis now.
Yeah.
I can do that with us talking about it.
I love the Patriots.
I can sit there and be like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Why did we draft that guy?
People just go,
don't go like you're not a patriot fed you like the jets.
You're a piece of shit.
So it's a very weird,
it's a weird time that you yeah,
because there's a bunch of people are afraid to say stuff that everybody kind of
agrees with.
Yeah.
But don't you think also that there's a lot of real like reasonable people that
are thinking the same thing you are on whatever issue,
thinking the same thing and when you do bring it up they agree.
And quietly go about their day.
Like normal people,
they come up after the show after they didn't laugh and say,
yeah,
I,
you're 100% right on the Bobo.
I totally agree with this.
Or I a dad just like that or whatever the fuck that you were talking about that
made the crowd required.
It's uh,
I,
you know what it really is.
I can't believe how many people are afraid to get in trouble.
Yeah.
Like basically get yelled at on Twitter.
Right?
By who?
Yeah.
Just the loudest,
loudest one.
Right.
It's just,
that's what I'm saying.
There's so many more people that aren't tweeting hateful stuffed at you.
I think most of it has to do with a corporation.
God forbid if one extra nickel that they could have made rolled out the fucking
door,
that's the only time they do the customer is always right,
is with that shit.
Right.
Everything else you can go fuck yourself.
You can go to the website and stare at the screen and try and figure it out
yourself and maybe you'll get a portion of a refund or something.
I don't want to get all gloom and doom here with this stuff.
So let's,
let's talk sports,
man.
Um,
I was really watching the red sox and,
uh,
then I just a duty,
I have to tell you what,
like this is the regular season man.
I know,
but it has been such a,
I'm a Yankee Fan.
Right.
And it has been,
by the way,
congratulations.
It's been,
must have been a fun ride your whole life.
It wasn't when I was a kid.
Well,
I had a little Greg nettles,
Reggie Jackson when I was really little and then I had to go the whole eighties
without his world series.
It was,
do you realize if you guys don't win it this year or next year,
that is the only second time.
You haven't won a world series during a a decade.
Yeah.
The level of success that,
that is fucking ridiculous.
Not to mention,
I think two decades.
You want at least half of them in the forties and 50s.
Well.
Yeah,
but I mean I can't,
I,
who knows what was going on back then and there was a Bobby socks and Frank
Sinatra one during my time.
Right.
We went through horrible periods when they were like trying to buy people and we
never [inaudible] was always messed up.
But the Jeter years,
homegrown kids,
Great Ronnie,
because you guy got,
guy got kicked out of baseball and he would've got rid of half of them.
I don't think cheater and I don't think he would have known what are you would
Mariano Rivera was going to be because nobody did.
Cause you guys had them pitch in like no,
but it'll relief.
I'll,
oh Neil would have been gone.
Bernie Williams would have been gone.
Well O'neil,
you got from the reds eat the,
they wouldn't,
they would not have hung onto these people.
He was,
but it was homegrown.
It was,
it was pure.
I have a guilt.
I have guilt as a Yankee fan when you buy in,
you know,
you've got Johnny Damon and all of a sudden any of the outfield.
I don't like that money part of it all.
We did,
we went right over the cliff with you.
We're like,
all right,
well they're in our division.
This is how you play and now you guys are doing it the right way.
We're doing it the right way and it's not a great season.
I Love Baseball,
my favorite sport and I'm enjoying the hell out of us.
Young guys scraping,
enjoying it.
The second best record in all of baseball and we can't get close to the red sox.
I want to.
This is what's great though.
What is so great is the greed of baseball where now they have to have 9 million
rounds.
Like back in the day.
If we slept,
swept you in August.
Yeah,
that would've been a big thing.
But back in the day I was sort of been as a red sox fan.
Like okay,
how are they going to fuck it up this time?
Cause they always did.
But that would immense something.
Yes.
That didn't really mean anything because,
because it doesn't mean anything.
Yeah,
because you guys are going to get the wild card.
We'll get one game play off against a Oakland or something and we'll lose them.
Be Out in one game of,
Oh,
why aren't you know,
I don't like the one.
What's the one game thing?
Well,
you have the one game,
the one game playoff.
Oh,
so they added that and then there's the three game and then the forest and then
the for the right.
But guys doing up there white to never,
you never lose.
You never lose.
How many wins do they have?
Uh,
last I checked the same way with like 91 and 41 or,
yeah,
we just got lucky in 41,
three.
So,
but no,
we were,
uh,
tonight.
I didn't,
well,
I'm taping this Sunday night too,
so don't confuse or you guys as good.
Are you guys as good as a,
as this record?
Sure.
No,
no.
Nobody ever is.
Your regular season record is never as good as you are because you're,
you're rolling up all these stats on people who aren't going to be there in
October.
So what you have to do is you've got to look at like we just played,
we just played uh,
the Indians who I think Terry Francona is still the best manager in baseball.
Everybody sleeping on them.
Nobody gets more out of their place in this fucking guy.
And we played a four game series,
we split it the first two games he made us look like a five on a ball club and
then our big free agent guys,
you know,
sale and price came in,
shut up,
down.
Right.
Okay.
Now here's the thing,
you fucking like Houston,
they got four landed to get all those guys did it.
Offending world series champion.
Nobody's talking about it.
They're so good.
Exactly.
And they probably had a couple of injuries and whatever,
blah blah blah blah blah.
All I know is come October were all zero and zero.
I think clearly there might pick to,
to take it again.
And what ESPN does about regulus seasons is what the news does about like Isis
where in my head isis was powerful enough to come over here,
attack this country and overthrow it.
Right.
Until I actually sat down,
I was like,
they don't have a plane or a boat or uniforms.
Right.
This is not Germany and Japan again.
Okay.
So,
uh,
it's fucking,
um,
they do the same thing with,
they basically said the race was over when we swept you guys four games in a
fucking wrong knowing.
Do we have like 12 games left?
Yeah.
Injuries happen to try and get to the one on the 18th or nine.
[inaudible] so I've,
I've Dude,
I've done this too many times.
He is a sports fan to know to try to put my feet up in August.
I eman say anything's over.
I watched his blow a 12 game lead.
Like I dunno how many years ago,
four,
five years ago.
I watched this blow,
that classic 18 game lead and 78.
Yeah,
I've,
I've seen the tuck rule.
I've seen the,
the fucking,
uh,
I've seen it all during this fat and roughing the passer.
There's still that insecure.
I've been beaten by my,
I've seen Paul's role through guy's legs is so great.
I was at dinner with my brother in law and his wife the other night and a red
sox fans and there's,
they would literally,
when we were talking,
we were still nine and a half up,
but yeah,
it was the Cleveland and they've lost the first game of Cleveland and the
Yankees won that night and we got a half game up and I was like,
here it comes.
Here comes the slide here.
This is the beginning of it again.
And I was just talking out of my ass because they're,
they're so solid.
But the fear in my brother in law's eyes like,
Oh man,
it really is.
This is the beginning of,
because he's gone through it,
like passing.
You get millennials.
They'd be like,
yeah,
fuck you.
We got this Yankee stuck.
They don't even,
they don't know.
No,
they don't.
Oh No.
I went to Fenway for the first time this year in the beginning of the season.
Horrible,
rainy night.
But,
uh,
that was my first time there.
I've watched so many games at Fenway on TV.
It was so surreal.
I felt like I had been there before.
Oh yeah.
When you're sitting in the thing,
like when you're walking through and trying to get food.
And so when I go back now,
it's not the ballpark I went to as a kid.
I mean they got like a mall in the right field and got people sitting up on the
green monster.
Right is so different from when I left the Green Moss,
which it didn't have any advertising,
anything.
I think it looks way better with the advertising and it's really in Ted Williams
days or pre Ted Williams,
dom dimaggio days or something.
I believe they had advertising there.
So it's gone through like a bunch of stuff.
But uh,
dude,
I was just thinking all this shit that I've seen,
I've seen the Celtics and a game seven with the Lakers scene.
The rest call thirtysomething files on them and like 15 on the Lakers in a game
seven.
I literally watched the Lakers beat us from the foul line and they,
and they,
these weren't,
we wasn't we out there hacking people.
It was so fucking anticlimactic of brutal.
I've seen too many men on the ice.
I,
I've,
I've too many.
Like,
I don't give a fuck how many games are up until,
but they also had taken out of your ball and you had the little snow plow to
give a thing for the guy who's shaken.
The every team has had those things.
All,
all of that shit.
Yeah,
that that too.
I have to tell you that deflate gate
is up there with any like as far as like the music man,
you could redo the music man with deflate gate.
They like to study.
Literally found that like the cults also had like three balls that were slightly
under inflated.
Espn did a study that showed that the ball actually got there a little bit
later.
So be an advantage to the defense defense.
So of course they pulled that immediately and a bunch of pats fans had recorded
at goal but they don't want you to know.
Right.
So why so why,
what?
Looking back now I feel like,
was it they don't do,
they did something they fucking,
cause we were in with with good Dell and then something happened and then we
would just fucking out.
I think part of it was I,
well I think part of it was when they under suspended ray rice,
uh,
and they were just like,
yeah,
a couple of games and then they tried to say that they didn't see it.
Then you found out they sought and then Goodell,
he's making like 35,
36 million a year.
Um,
then I think he just started over suspending everybody.
And do you think it's like if we go after the golden boy that'll kind of take
the heat off of the whole league?
No.
What I think what ended up happening,
I think we in the combination was that,
and then we had some sort of falling out with the guy and then we took them to
court in a court of law.
I mean the,
it got laughed out of court.
That judge actually yelled at the NFL for wasting their time.
Really?
So a lot of people forget that.
So then he played the next year not suspended.
So then what,
you know now you can't have double jeopardy.
You can't get tried for the same thing.
So the NFL went back and changed their argument and said,
and said,
is the NFL a corporation?
And they said yes.
And they says,
does a corporation have a right to suspend an employee?
And they,
and they,
if they feel fit.
And they said yes.
And they said,
well,
Tom Brady is an employee of our corporation and he is,
he is suspended.
And they couldn't mess with that.
So that's what we got.
That's easiest.
So he sat down for four games because if Tom Brady and the Patriots took the NFL
to court and won and reversed it,
that was going to open the floodgates every time helmet to helmet head and
suspension,
all this could potentially,
you know,
our corporation thinks like,
oh my God,
the amount of money in legal costs we'll have then not flooding the nut house.
They had to fucking suspend them.
Right.
So that is my totally bias patriots.
Yeah.
You know,
as far as like we take an air out of the ball,
we tried to steal signs.
Yes.
As is everybody else.
Which is why when you watch a college football game,
my favorite thing ever when you watched them,
when they send in to signals,
there's like four guys doing it right?
Somebody holding up a picture of Urkel.
But guys,
you know fucking pop lockin you know,
and I also love to like that whole idea that if you film somebody,
you know what they're doing,
like they're miming throwing the ball or handing it off for punting it.
You still have to figure it out.
And as much as we were guilty with the of of the spy gate thing,
I mean if you're going to sit there and say,
oh yeah,
first of all,
everyone else's pure,
well the thing about that is is that was the first game that that was illegal to
do that.
What do you mean those are not well that that was legal.
You are allowed to,
Jimmy Johnson even said,
he goes,
I came in the league,
they say,
okay,
what do I do?
He you to get a camera pointed at their guy looking at halftime,
whatever you can steal,
steal.
Oh really?
So I think it just looked bad after awhile.
So the rule was to just that you couldn't have a guy on the field.
You can still have a guy up in the booth.
There's something called a Zoom Lens.
It's still doing it.
Yeah.
Everybody is still fucking doing it.
So it's funny.
Yeah.
So if you're going to spend any money,
you're going to say steal in science than we should have to forfeit World War
II.
You have a college team that you like or you're like,
yes,
yes.
I have a bunch that I like,
but Lsu is my adopted one.
That's your adopted,
I just loved the a sec.
Uh,
this was 10 years ago,
about 2008 I was after on.
Nick Saban was there and I was into a les miles and you know,
he would keep it just to that ship,
you know,
it was almost like he was,
his offensive mind was where the people in the upper deck was where they like go
forth
and he would just do it.
Yeah.
And it worked for a little while.
The LSU,
they're big.
They're big thing is they've never,
they,
and since I've been watching them,
they haven't had a quarterback that they've believed in enough to let him play
the full game.
And they are literally playing a lot of times the stereotypical like old school
stereotypical white quarterback,
a black quarterback thing where it's like it's a passing down.
Get the white guy in there.
Right.
So running the,
we could maybe run the option here,
get the black guy in there and it's just like,
dude,
that's hilarious.
Pick one.
Go and let them get into the,
the,
the feel of the game as it,
it'd be like,
Hey Tom,
I never liked hosting.
Yeah.
Cause it's like you get,
I'm going to get him gone and then you've got to bring somebody up at such an
art and then you sit down,
you fucking,
you know,
thinking about your day the next day and it's like,
Oh fuck,
I've got to run back and do another five minutes.
Yeah.
Um,
my favorite thing and hosting was we're going to,
yeah,
we're going to keep the show moving right along and bring the next guy up.
That was my favorite thing.
Posting.
I'm not going to do any time in between.
Are we going to keep this?
I'm just murders or is it going to keep the show going?
Yeah,
I kind of,
I really like,
uh,
have the comedy store doesn't have a host.
I really like,
yeah,
how they,
they just bring everybody up.
You just bring each other on.
I didn't,
I didn't think I was gonna like that.
It's,
it's pretty awesome.
Oh,
you want to talk about a place that just turned around?
I don't know if you ever,
I was living out here in the late nineties and when you went down to the comedy
store,
I mean also no one knew who I was.
I was struggling to get spots,
but that place,
first of all,
there was nobody there.
No Spooky.
Yeah.
And it was like,
oh,
to the vibe.
I was like,
it was like,
I was like a fucking haunted house.
Like you went in there and there was all of these guys,
these guys that were on TV and they were big names and they would come in and
just burn the light.
They would just stand there.
Yeah,
having not done the work now,
didn't write anything new.
We're just standing there leaning against the Mike Stang.
Yeah.
So what else is going on but blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And you're sitting back there,
you know your spots pushed back.
Five minutes,
10 minutes,
40 minutes,
an hour and a half,
two hours.
I'm going home.
I can't go home if I go home.
They don't know me.
So I,
I you just have to,
would have to fucking stay there group.
And um,
and all these young kids were learning.
Some day when I get on his shelf,
I'm going to do that.
And I,
and I remember
being here in [inaudible] 98 it was right as Seinfeld was wrapping up and Jerry,
the first time ever,
all these years I had been out there,
he popped in at the Improv and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Right.
It's the king.
And he went on stage,
was supposed to do 15 minutes.
He did 15 minutes,
right.
He started with the killer job.
He ended with a great job.
Even better joking in the middle.
He tried out as new stuff and I just,
I just clicked.
I was like,
that's the way you do it.
That's a fucking pro.
Right.
And that other shit is just ego and oh that's all it is.
I got a show going and oh yeah,
yeah,
no that place was spooked.
I remember going there,
the store back then and there was like,
this is not going to be a help me.
Like this isn't going to make me depressed.
It was,
it was,
there was fucking hostile.
It was really was.
It was hostile.
And I remember,
uh,
there was a couple rays of light over there,
rogue.
And I remember meeting Rogan for the first time at the laugh factory and I
rolled over yet.
Of course he had this fucking Badass,
cool car,
Korean words.
That's really what I remember about those days.
It was just watching Joe come in a really cool car.
Like wow,
that guy's really got it going on.
Yeah,
he did some sick ass tail fin.
There was some sort of Japanese sports car,
I can't remember.
So some turbo powered something and we went over there and this and he basically
gave me like a pep talk.
Oh yeah.
On the mindset you hit,
but it wasn't split,
wasn't specifically pointed at the comedy store and it was just the La comedy
scene.
Right,
right.
Like how you had to be,
don't fucking listen to anybody,
get in there,
do your job and just like,
it was like a real,
like it was like an eight point powered Joe Rogan PowerPoint thing that's great
on the mindset and that like,
and he was like,
he was young.
Yeah.
Joe.
So he was like,
it was like,
is this Guy gonna like help me a fucking rip my head off.
Like he was like the most amped up dude I'd ever fucking been around.
Uh,
and uh,
fortunately he turned out to be like just a sweetheart of a guy.
Yeah.
And really the kind of the heart of what turned that place around.
Like he will do him calling out fucking Mitsui and all that.
Like,
dude,
I always like it was,
it was fucking ridiculous.
I was like coming in there with a big can of raid and just bring it all across
the whole comedy store.
It was unbelievable because like the terror that you had,
yeah.
You believe,
Hey,
he pulled in,
he pulled in the thing and you're like,
fuck,
I'm going on next.
And all the work you wanted to do you could not do.
You could not fucking do.
I mean I want to start that shit up again,
but like it's amazing now.
I mean when you walk in there now,
it just,
just the original route just to go and have a place to really work.
Like you really are going to get work done.
Yeah.
And what's funny is looking at Rogen,
look how big Rogan is and what does he do?
He does it like Seinfeld you 15 he goes up,
he does 15 tries out the shit he wants to try out.
He kills,
you know,
work on your stuff and go.
But it's amazing though that usually wants to place or a scene goes bad like
that.
It's very rare that it comes.
Yeah.
It's like a movie in a movie that happens.
I know,
but triumphs over evil.
Yeah.
But similar to what you were saying about seller being like that special room
and something just happens there.
Places have something to them.
Yeah.
The laugh factory is always going to be the laugh factory.
The sellers always going to be the seller.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
it was unreal,
man.
You may dip and have bad times,
but that room is begging to be good again.
Yeah.
You don't really know what the one that I remember way back in the day,
uh,
in the 90s we were coming up,
if you on the nine o'clock show Saturday night at the comic Strip,
Oh my God.
I made it with,
so it was like you'd come off and think you are the greatest comedian of all
time.
Yeah.
I'm ready to do Letterman.
That room,
the energy of that square room,
that centered stage.
Yeah.
It was unreal.
On that one and that route.
And that's a club that's,
that's gone in the toilet and it's just waiting to come back.
You put the right person,
booking it and start attracting the good guys back again cause that room,
the architecture,
the energy when up when human beings are in it,
it's waiting to be great.
I was still in New York,
I would still go there even if it's going through a bad period.
It's just like just to keep it going.
Yeah.
Then you got to use,
we use whatever juice you have to key cause of.
How does that help comics?
If there's one less room,
forget about a room like that,
which you do that.
That room was fucking crazy.
Crazy,
crazy.
Do you remember when uh,
over the,
where the names,
the team red Johnny and the Round Guy.
Oh God.
When they would go up at the comic strip,
I mean I had to follow him at the fucking Boston Comedy Club.
Nothing was bigger.
Nothing was bigger that they would just rip the roof off that place.
I mean to,
what do we,
we don't like when they,
when they used to be down to the fucking Boston comedy club and they,
and they would do the fucking the,
that it takes to,
well it takes two to make a thing go right.
And one of them is gone.
And then remember Matt Frost,
who's now at CIA,
he would be flicking the lights fucking on and off.
Like it was a nightclub and the place would be going nuts.
They were some show,
it was some joke that they did yeah.
About going to a dance club and feel like an asshole.
And they just like when they went into that bit,
uh,
it was like,
you are at a fuck.
It's like you started watching a movie.
Yeah.
And you'd be shocked.
I remember just standing there going like,
I have nothing,
nothing,
nothing in my arsenal in my whole career.
Never.
You could take all of it and slam it together.
I have nothing that could follow that.
And Oh my God.
And going up in that fucking room after those guys and bombing was the loneliest
fucking thing.
Like,
I mean I,
if I ever saw comics start crying and that I wouldn't even judge them.
And now that was back to when the club where all the comics sat in the back.
But you had to walk to the front of the stage and go up in the middle before
they had that side.
Yes.
And they would just be back there.
And I remember I was,
this kid came down from Boston,
nobody gave a fuck.
Yeah.
I remember running into Todd Barry Cohen like going like,
ah,
how do I get any like asking you that fucking question where there is no answer.
How do I get in at the clubs?
He's like,
yeah,
I dunno man.
Just keep doing it.
Yeah,
just you got to hang out.
I said,
I know.
And I now I know what he was thinking.
Like,
hey dude,
I'm trying,
I'm still trying to get it,
you know,
and you'd sit back there and you'd watch like a towel and Kevin,
Brandon,
all these guys that were like already made men.
Like in the end,
everybody had an edge and there was no like joy of like come on along the,
I'll show you the way it was just mean tough guys who got a spot and you weren't
taking it from them and screw you to this day member to stay til two o'clock in
the morning and let me,
I dare you to complain.
Yeah,
I dare you.
And it was a bunch of comics they used to hide uptown cause they didn't want to
go downtown and get there.
They went down there once it takes two to make it take you already.
Fuck that shit.
I am not going below fucking 23rd street and they they,
it was scary.
It was scary down there.
It was a,
it was like Armageddon and the,
but I used to walk by the Boston during the day when it had that shit read
awning that looked turned pink.
Yeah.
It looks like an old peep show bill fucking front.
I used to,
I used to get sick to my stomach when I would look at it and I and I,
and that was the main Dredd where I was just like I have to get over this
fucking feeling or I am not going to make it in this city.
I know cause that is fucking not,
I'm just walking by the building and it's like that bully I have to fight.
Yes.
Completely.
I remember saying to Kevin Brennan,
we were up at the standup New York and uh,
he's like,
was talking just about this and I said yeah,
but you know,
we gotta keep going cause it's making a stronger,
right.
We got to go cause it makes it a stronger Kevin goes,
it's,
it's comedy.
I mean how fucking strong do we have to be?
Yeah.
I remember this comic to bitch and say that they should,
they should be no heckling.
This should be no heckling.
He's like,
you go to a Broadway show,
there's no heckling and I don't want to be like,
well fucking gold.
Fucking get a job on Broadway then do.
Cause I,
I don't think that there should be any heckling that's like,
I think that's what makes stand up so fucking cool is that yeah,
that is actually,
you know,
that's part of it that somebody is going to do that.
Yeah.
That there's the energy that something's get it,
that this is going to be different tonight than it was last night.
And I will say because of me,
it might be cause the audience maybe because of the Moon,
who knows?
And the fact that people heckle is also what keeps a lot of people from never it
weeds out a lot of people.
Yeah.
Which is a gun belt on both sides.
I don't want to keep you here too long.
I know you're,
you're onto a bunch of other podcasts to promote your show.
I stay here all day.
Um,
we'll also,
we want to have enough time for going to fix the guard.
Maybe.
Who knows?
Start one.
Finish it at home.
Yeah,
he could do that.
All right,
let's do that.
Let's do that.
Tom Papa,
the show's called baked.
It comes on September,
September 3rd day night.
10 date,
two episodes.
Starts at 10 o'clock east 10 o'clock.
Cause in September 3rd,
and it's going to run every Monday through September.
The first one is,
uh,
the first one actually is New York and my buddy,
our buddy Jim Gaffigan steps by a doughnut shop while I'm there.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah,
it's great.
All right.
I've already pitched myself for the second season.
I came.
All right dude.
So happy for your success buddy.
Thank you buddy.
All right.
See the best.
Oh,
right,
okay.
Yeah,
it's time for the reeds here.
I apologize to all the people that wrote in above the farmers down there and,
uh,
South Africa.
I'm going to read up on that and I will read the rest of that guy's email.
Um,
um,
on Thursday.
Okay.
That's my promise.
Now if you know me,
I'm scatterbrained,
so I might forget.
Okay.
But,
uh,
I don't take innocent people dying anywhere lightly.
It had nothing to do with that and do the other bullshit.
All right,
with that,
let's,
uh,
do some reads here.
Oh,
men mobile.
what do you get gum when you fucking fill of vks ticked.
Um,
mint mobile.
Uh,
the big in big wireless providers stands for a lot of things.
Big Contracts,
big bill's big phase,
big pain in the fork in HD.
What big wireless doesn't want you to know is that there's a way to cut your
wireless build down to just 15 bucks a month.
No Way,
man.
How was that possible?
Introducing
Mint Mobile,
the game changing company that takes everything into one that's taken
everything.
Oh,
sorry.
Wrong with big wireless and made it right.
Are Crusaders.
Mint mobile makes it so easy to cut your wireless bill down to just 15 bucks a
month.
Use Your own phone with any mint mobile plan.
Okay.
These guys aren't like separate but equal.
Then I go on,
uh,
down the south here in the 1960s and fifties.
Um,
they're user friendly here.
You can use your own phone with any mid mobile plan.
You can keep your old number along with all your existing contacts.
Choose between two,
five or 10 gigabyte,
four g LTE plans.
Every plan comes with unlimited talk and text.
Jesus Christ.
I'm going to get this unlimited talk and text.
And if you're not 100% satisfaction satisfied mid mobile has you covered with
their seven day money back guarantee?
Well,
when does the fucking bill camp comes once a month?
How does that work?
Thanks to mid mobile wireless never has to be expensive again.
And to prove that to prove that meant mobile is going to hook you up.
Going to hook up 10 of my listeners with free wireless for a year.
Holy Shit.
Seriously free wireless for a year.
Enter to win one year of mint mobile service with five gigabytes of data per
month.
Um,
10 potential winners will be drawn from eligible entries received between August
27th and September 10th a and you write me if you win it because I want to make
sure that they give us all 10 winners will be announced September 15th,
2018 visit mint
mobile.com/burr B u r.
R for your chance to win.
And for the complete official rules meant mobile.com/burr no purchases necessary
and open to legal residents of the 50 United States,
us states,
and the district of Columbia.
You must be 18 years or older at time of entry.
All right,
now Robin Hood.
Robin Hood is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
FTF,
ss,
whatever the fuck those are options and Crypto crypto Rodeos all commissioned
free.
When a cryptos what do you invest in in fucking robots in the future?
You creep,
uh,
they strive to make financial services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy pigs,
non non intimidating way for stock market and newcomers to invest for the first
time with true confidence.
Now the stock market is just like gambling in Vegas,
only play with money you can afford to loose.
All right,
simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data,
uh,
presented in an easy to digest way.
Values of the Robinhood APP are as follows,
costs slash no commission fees.
Other brokerages charge up to $10 for every trade.
But Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
fee trade,
uh,
fees,
trade stocks and keeps and keep all of your profits.
Sorry,
I could read that a little more clearly.
Other brokers charge up the 10 bucks for every trade.
But Robin who doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profits.
Everybody.
It's easy to use,
easy to understand and charts and market data.
Place a trade and just four taps on your smartphone.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections.
100 most popular sectors like entertainment,
social media and curated categories like female CEOs for a little reverse sexism
there.
But you know,
they female CEOs probably need help,
right?
Help out the ladies and invest in their companies provided it's a good company.
You know,
the end of the day he can be part of a cause,
but it's your money there.
And analysts,
analysts,
a ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
Learn how to invest and build your portfolio.
Robinhood is giving less listeners a free stock like apple,
like Robin Hood is giving listeners a free,
a free stock like apple,
Ford or sprint to help build your portfolio.
That's hilarious.
They're undercutting sprint and let you invest in them.
So they're good guys.
Sign
up@billburrarobinhood.com.
That's bill
burr.robinhood.com I read it wrong the first time.
Bill Bar Dot Robin hood.com.
All right.
Oh look who's back.
Indo Chino.
Uh,
talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
I don't know how to do this anymore.
You know what?
Every man looks good in this suit.
No matter how long that tie is dangling between their junk,
the end of the day,
they look better than,
than,
than walking around.
You know,
here's the thing.
You want to meet a woman?
Okay?
You gotta take respect in the way you dress.
All right?
And I know you want to be that guy.
Dress down Friday all the frigging time,
but I'm telling you,
you put on a little habit dash Sheree,
they're all right.
They,
they,
you take a risk,
you show a little respect for yourself
and the ladies will notice,
you know,
I wonder if they make like those power suits that Hillary Clinton war for the
ladies.
I have no idea.
Additional copy points for Indochino is it's the world's largest made to measure
men's wear company and has been featured in major publications including Gq,
Forbes in something called fast company.
Uh,
they make suits and shirts made to your exact measurements from great fed guys.
Love will love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details,
including your lapel lining and monogrammed.
Okay.
This is like Conor Mcgregor Shit.
For someone like myself who doesn't know how to fight,
how great this Conor McGregor look at every way or whatever,
whenever he sitting there talking shit about everybody killing it better than
most comics.
I know the man always looks well.
Why?
It always looks great because he is a designer.
Suits.
You could do it too.
Here's how it works.
Visited showroom or shop online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customization,
submit your measurements way for your customers suit to arrive in just a few
weeks,
and then he got accustomed suit.
So if you show up where everybody else has a suit on,
they just bought it off the rack,
they don't got their initials there,
then I'll get that snazzy lining that you're going to have right.
Visit a showroom or shop online@indochino.com uh,
this week my listeners can get any premium Indochino suit for just 379
bucks@indochino.com that's probably what,
how much does it fucking Conor Mcgregor's pocket square costs?
But you're working your way up when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% 50% off the regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code per for any premium suit,
three and $79.
It's incredible deal for a soup that will fit you better than anything off the
rack ever will.
All right.
Ah,
[inaudible] [inaudible] they're killing all the fucking farmers do to
[inaudible] beyond these.
And then they go get some Schwannoma that take the land back that was stolen
from fucking innocent people.
Where does it end?
At least your balls will be nice in software and they come in with the fucking
machetes.
Um,
Mandy's,
sorry.
Uh,
you've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
I just rhymed.
Farmers were Shwarma.
That's not bad,
Huh?
I showed a little fucking m and m there.
You Know Ben's The fucking word.
All right bill.
It didn't Ryan,
whatever.
I thought it was pretty good on the fly.
You know the fun comfy undies that feel as good as they look to those of you who
haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You get incredible underwear sent to your door with me on these meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough.
Just picture you walking around and your skivvies drop in trial is a trial.
I was always dropping trout for the longest time,
but it's travel like you putting the,
you're taking down your trousers,
which always reminds me of that Louis Ck joke when he was talking about calling
up a phone sex line and you always get that old woman talking dirty to them.
I'm going to take off your trousers.
Um,
some jokes just stick with me,
meaning no more hunting around for the blah,
blah,
blah.
Me undies are made what they sustainably sourced material from beechwood trees.
This is how confident these guys are.
They're putting trees in their underwear and somehow it's still more comfortable
than cotton.
There's naturally sought fiber makes a fabric that won't sag down or the rep,
trust me,
I got a pair of these that all of this is true.
Once you put on a pair of you're going to get it.
Um,
and if you're already part of the me undies fam,
not family fam that trying to meet you,
they're trying to reach the millennials on that line when you're part of the me
undies fam,
Yo,
tell your friends about it.
Uh,
through their referral program.
They'll get a discount and you'll get a store credit.
It's a win win.
Still not sure.
What else do I got to tell you?
Well,
the undies has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 15% off their first pair of me undies and shipping is
free.
That's 15% off free shipping and a guarantee that you and your me undies.
We'll be very happy together.
Get your ass over to [inaudible] dot com and treat yourself,
uh,
to get 50% off your first pair and free shipping.
100%.
It's 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr that's Mandy's dot com slash bird.
All right,
two more.
Hang in there.
Oh,
it's old zip.
Hiring used to be hard.
I don't know who to pick.
Moon.
Multiple job sites.
Stacks of resumes,
a confusing review process.
Jesus Christ.
Where does it end?
But today,
hiring can be easy and you only have to go to one place to get it done.
Zip
recruiter.com/burr.
Uh,
when you go to zip
a,
they send you your,
uh,
zip recruiter,
sends your job's to over 100 of the web's leading job boards.
They don't stop there.
Most people would stop there,
but not ZipRecruiter with their power from matching technology,
zip ZipRecruiter's scans,
thousands of job resumes to find people with the right experience and invite
them to apply for your position.
As applications come in,
zip
analyzes each one and spotlights the top candidates.
So you now you don't have to fuck around with people who aren't qualified,
so you never miss a great match.
Ziprecruiter is so effective that 80% of employers who post on Ziprecruiter get
a quality candidate through the site within the first day.
Time is money.
Ziprecruiter understands this was with results like that.
It's no wonder why zip
code is the highest rated hiring site in America right now.
My listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at the exclusive web address,
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/burr spell out birth.
Okay.
B U r r once again,
that sip.
Yeah,
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] ZipRecruiter is the smartest way to hire.
And lastly,
but certainly not leastly the headliner of all my advertising for the most part,
stamps.com they've been with me since the beginning.
They us postal services and important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 seven right?
Your wife went to bed,
your kids are in bed,
you're going to get a jump on your day.
You pour yourself a scotch and yet you printouts of Goddamn postage.
Print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact amount,
excuse me,
the executive,
the hiccups,
the exact amount of postage every time,
never under pay for overpaid again.
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business by and print official US postage.
This is getting redundant for any letter,
any package,
any class,
the mail,
using your own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale and automatically calculates the exact postage,
the post office and all their wonderful shit that they do down there is now in
your house stamps.com we'll leave and help you decide the best class of mail for
your needs.
You can do it in the nude.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
which I really need to advertise better.
I have autographed posters,
these amazing posters that people have told me I could sell for 40 bucks at a
show,
but you know what?
I'm a man of the people.
All right?
I only sell them for 20 bucks.
Their autograph there,
right?
Every one of my goddamn shows and people keep walking out and then they texted
me after,
hey man,
I want to see the poster.
Where is it?
It's out there in the,
I don't know where.
All right,
I'm sidetracked,
but I use stamps.com to send these fuckers out.
Alright.
stamps.com I use stamps.com I just told you why and right now you too can enjoy
stamps.com stamps.com service with this special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter burn.
All right.
By the way,
as I mentioned before,
my great Buddy Dean del Ray's doing his first talk show as a standup comedian,
uh,
tonight,
Monday night on Conan O'brien with the great and brilliant Mark Marin is one of
the guests.
Um,
please tune in and uh,
and check it out.
And after that it says they got a ton of emails,
tons of emails about,
uh,
from South Africa.
So I have to read these.
I can at least read the rest of this guy.
Um,
his thing here,
I forgot where I left off.
Look,
let's just pick this up,
which brings me to my second point.
Now.
I don't follow all the news on Trump.
Frankly,
I don't care anymore because it's exhausting.
I agree.
I agree too.
Everybody's screaming and yelling and flipping the fuck out and nobody has a
solution.
Uh,
but the message I get from the media is still the same.
They hate him and we'll blow up any small thing just to take them down and
basically,
you know,
something that is a problem in this country.
Ever since Bill Clinton,
no one has been allowed to be president without being constantly under attack.
And I really think it hurts to position Democrat,
Republican,
or Libertarian,
whatever.
You got to let the person try to do the fucking job,
you know.
Anyways,
they hate him and we'll blow up anything you'd dedicate.
Basically they're saying Trump has chosen debate,
team Ei,
therefore we will choose opposing team.
Be A,
that is true with CNN and Fox.
They both do it.
Everybody is making a big deal over every bombshell in quotes.
Uh,
in the Mueller probe of he must have known and this lawyer knew about that shit
and pleaded guilty.
Really?
Do you want to tell me Hillary Clinton or any other politician would have the
same kind of,
uh,
at that you've wanted to say wouldn't have the same kind of during,
yeah.
Hillary would have been getting attack the entire fucking time.
They all played dirty.
I would never have expected otherwise.
So my point is,
yeah,
but they don't all play dirty.
Bernie Sanders did not play dirty,
which why I don't think it's a waste of a vote to even know the guy's not going
to win to a vote for somebody like that because you're trying to encourage more
people by seeing the amount of votes that you can get by being a good fucking
person.
A people say you wasted your vote.
Anyways.
Um,
so my point is Trump actually noticed a problem in South Africa that requires
attention,
but we probably won't get the attention we need because the dumb ass media is
too busy writing South Africa hit back at Trump articles.
Uh,
that's true.
They tried to take down everything that he's doing.
But the thing about it is,
is he only seems to notice problems that hit white people.
Okay.
That's the fucking problem.
And,
and in as much as our media definitely would have attacked any republican that
went in there,
the the left wing media would definitely do that.
I mean,
I think when you look at Neo Nazis and go,
yeah,
well I mean did you know people were being aggressive on both sides.
You kind of lose a lot of credibility is all I'm saying.
All right.
But I understand also what you're saying.
Okay.
Continuing.
Um,
wow.
You read it all the way up to here.
Thanks.
Go be an inspiration to all the other hairless ginger's out there.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so there's another one from South Africa.
Bill Clinton's balanced budget myth.
All right.
So it wasn't balanced.
Now I have to want like where did this come from now is this people on the
right?
Yeah.
You don't know where any of this is from.
So now I have to,
I'm just supposed to read this and I'm supposed to look at you and assume that
you're as this guy down the middle,
that votes on both sides.
I will,
I will read this.
You guys are making me more informed,
I think.
Or maybe you're swaying me like that guy who wrote in from Russia,
but I don't know if that's the guy from Russia who's hacked into the Twitter
shit.
I don't know where any of this shit's coming from a shark theft.
Hey,
bill just wanted to share this ridiculous story about this guy that stole a
fucking shark from an aquarium in Texas.
He dressed the shark is a baby and put it on a push chair and just walked out.
His justification was,
he was concerned for the sharks welfare.
Well,
he probably wanted to put it back in the ocean,
but,
uh,
once he takes it out of the water,
I think the shark was like,
hey man,
I don't think that aquarium was,
was so bad.
Granted,
it's not as big as the ocean,
and I'm no longer to live freely as a living thing on this planet.
But,
uh,
you know,
if the shark went to rescue you and stuck you dressed you as a baby and put you
in a fucking carriage and then took you under water,
I think you'd be like
[inaudible]
yeah.
Oh,
there is still some due process in this country.
The fact that the article says a man man accused of stealing shark.
I mean,
I think the fact that he had it,
you know,
oh,
I thought this was like,
I thought that was part of the gift bag after you went to the aquarium that you
could take one of the fish home.
All right.
Robin Leach,
uh,
Billy Benz,
you're old enough to remember lifestyles of the rich and famous.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That was great.
That's one of the first,
uh,
the sort of MTV cribs before MTV cribs.
This Guy Robin Leach and they glorified in and was just all like,
and when they sitting at the pool,
there is,
don't sit at the pool they eat as cargo.
I love watching it.
Uh,
do an impression for the kids who don't know what he sounded like.
I can't do an impression of him.
I haven't seen it long enough and I'm not good at impressions unless the persons
in my life,
um,
like I can imitate,
I can imitate.
I'm working on a Dean del Rey,
then I'm going to get like a,
he always comes back from concert.
Hey Dean,
how was it?
Ah,
dude,
it was cute.
He always goes down or if he's talking about some of the,
there's an asshole.
Oh,
they're gay.
Okay.
That guy's a garbage can.
All right.
The first show to really give you a look at how filthy rich some people are,
was the lifestyles of the rich and famous.
I remember seeing an onyx black bathtub and just thinking that all rich people
had black sinks and bathroom fixtures.
All right?
For those of you who didn't grow up in the 80s,
if somebody had an all black bathroom,
they were into cocaine on an entirely different level.
They were going,
uh,
Kleinfeld.
You remember Kleinfeld Manuel the most underrated Sean Penn character of all
fucking time a car in Carlito's way.
You gotta check that out where he was.
When I love when Pitino said that lie lawyer.